yeah welcome to this video I had a
technical problem so I'm 15 seconds down
playing just one guitar and then let's
play this f3 lineout recommended this in
my serious so should play it from time
to time yeah 95 d take c5 is the main
line of this opening
yeah this has been played quite a lot
and the last couple of years not quite
sure what the most precise move on is
now queen before is in God's knight c6
and I certainly don't know is he
threatening to take not sure but I mind
I know I shouldn't I give the pawn back
immediately sir yeah this line is
actually fairly safe for white it so you
get this pawn and black um interesting
get this poem on on c5 and black quite
often need to um yeah compromise himself
a bit to get it back it's not so easy to
get it back sometimes like here how does
he get the pawn back after night takes
play night age 32 f to covering the d3
square 9075 d3s one issue and I think
night age 32 f 2 will cover that maybe
am happened when I was about to mention
this maybe you should think about taking
with the bishop but what now I still
like this actually f 2 D 3 is not bad at
all
yeah white of course is not owned not a
clear porn up and play can can play a
technical game here this is not the case
but it's still fairly comfortable hard
to imagine how you how you lose this
position okay how to play the snow night
c4 should I play move like a five to get
this post on deform if I've by black as
a move that I really don't want to see
you yeah maybe the bishop is nicely
placed on deform I know I give away the
D Phi square but I can fight for the
scrubs night at forum okay maybe even
tonight you for coming
yeah it's not so easy to play for for
black not sure that this really helps 94
is may be happy i can go to c5 actually
95
and maybe Nancy form just maybe problem
could be maybe you could have even take
another plane I'd be three
yeah it's a tricky for black I thought I
think he had some some idea or some some
improvement maybe even taking a night be
3dr rather weird but you sure there was
something
yeah here black is always tied to this
beats and porn so what now connecting
looks like networks
this one may be preventing not c4 and
here doesn't really want to take I think
proving my position okay he takes takes
Knight c4 it's okay
yeah maybe I maybe I did something wrong
him
yes this doesn't look like any
substantial thing anymore not quite sure
what the problem was and I'm not sure
that I had something something big
anyway but I did felt like fat like
something at least
yeah the Sun is very dry okay of course
maybe and this is a weakness a bit of a
weakness but nothing serious I'm still a
bit more active with the rook on a seven
but nothing that really should yeah be
of any big importance yeah we should be
too young okay wait this is not even
going to i can i can actually do that
now check check
check yeah this is made and it was
slightly tricky fine what slightly
tricky I think one problem was this g5
move it's still a draw I'm not saying
that it's still a drawin not the g5 but
then at least I have home I have some
idea okay okay now and this I don't know
it's it's it's slightly slightly tricky
I Roxy for with the check with the check
you can must play this one Jack Jack
yeah yeah it's still in a blitz game
it's still tricky if I'm the only one to
to have any sort of idea but it should
be it wrong yeah somewhere here maybe
there was something but i'm not i'm not
really sure where
yeah maybe maybe taking on b7 hmm I
thought you would just take a look be
one this is the computers idea if you
want I only thought there should be six
rupee one a strong though yeah this is
this is something this is something the
problem is after this black ass in no
position to take because of the back
rank and now the night is dominated on
the rim something like h5 for example I
have this one and this is something I'm
maybe not sure if you can can window
somewhere to the you can you can play on
with a clear conscience am NOT playing
on time ok thanks for watching